turn now to the coronavirus in a cbs
news poll showing more frustration with
president biden's response
only about half of americans in our
polls say that the president is doing a
good job of handling this pandemic
that's down from just over two-thirds in
march of last year the president's chief
of staff says we've made historic
progress but it is still a challenge as
ed o'keefe reports the u.s surgeon
general says and no one wants to hear
this part that the newest covet
challenge will be with us for a while
longer
we shouldn't expect a national peak in
the next coming days next few weeks will
be tough surgeon general dr vivek murthy
defending the biden administration's
response to the pandemic as the number
of daily cases surged to nearly 800
thousand as the president said we
certainly have more we need to do on
testing and that's a message that's very
clear from him to the public to his team
that we need to pull every lever
possible but a new cbs news poll finds a
little more than a third of americans
think attempts to contain the virus are
going well and a growing number of
people say information about the
pandemic shared by officials is
confusing quite frankly they're falling
short in a couple of ways maryland
republican governor larry hogan says
states need more help from the federal
government the president announced
nearly a month ago before christmas that
he was going to distribute these
half a billion
rapid tests out across the country and
so far we haven't seen any another
challenge for the president most
disapprove of how he's handling the
economy and inflation the inflation
issue is real we've got to tackle it
some of the inflation is is related to
the continuing pandemic
so how could the president turn things
around well based on our poll americans
say it's by focusing more on inflation
and less on new legislation among those
who disapprove of the president more
than six in 10 of them say opinions of
him would improve if mr biden is able to
get inflation down that's more than
double the number who say they'd think
better of him if the president's social
spending plan is passed or if democrats
pass new voting rights bills democrats
are going to try to do that later this
week but of course they're expected to
face republican opposition tony
all right ed thank you very much